this is the moment mahalo orlovsky was
captured by russian forces his arms in
the air on top of an armored vehicle
by this point his car is being driven by
a russian soldier
the images captured on his own dash cam
and then published online by a russian
journalist
smith
earlier in the dashcam feed you see
mihailo greeting ukrainian fighters
he was a civilian taxi driver but was
helping as a military volunteer in the
northern region of chernohith
nearly 500 ukrainian civilians are
currently in russian prisons mihailo was
swapped in a prisoner exchange in april
this is his story of russian detention
[Music]
after his arrest on the 7th of march he
was stripped and kept in a deep hole in
the ground for two days in this forest
before being flown by helicopter to a
prison in kursk russia
it was this russian mug shot published
online that first gave mahalo's family
news he was still alive so you were
exchanged on your mum's birthday the
10th of april
yeah at what point did you get to speak
to her
oh yeah
um
um
um
has since returned to the scene where he
was taken his personal belongings still
lying on the ground
his car burnt out the serial number
still visible but he's escaped with an
important message for the world on the
horrors for ukrainian civilians in
russian detention
sally lockwood sky news keeve